and happening now a one and four year
old suffer critical injuries in a
possible dui crash cheyenne and pecos as
you can see from this live image shut
down right now while police get a closer
look at how this three-car crash
happened so let's get right out to sasha
loftus for more on the situation
denise and bryan this intersection is
completely closed as this investigation
continues you can see the crash behind
me a pretty serious situation again two
small children as you mentioned are
seriously hurt tonight officers tell us
this happened around eight o'clock when
a pickup truck was speeding on pecos hit
an suv making a left turn and both were
thrown into a third car we're told both
a one-year-old and a four-year-old were
in critical condition earlier tonight
the one-year-old is now stable according
to officers but the four-year-old is
still fighting to survive dui and speed
are both suspected as factors in this
crash several others were hurt but are
expected to be okay now as i said this
is still a serious situation
investigators on scene still working on
this developing story so this area
cheyenne and pecos should stay closed
for a while longer so avoid the area if
you can and of course stay with eight
news now for developments both on air
and online reporting live in north las
vegas tonight sasha loftis live local
now